remember Pam Bondi the Florida Attorney
General she is going to be going to work
for the Trump administration with
reportedly a position in the White House
you should remember her she's been
involved in a number of scandals
involving Donald Trump the Trump
foundation is under investigation
because it allegedly improperly used its
campaign funds including a $25 donation
to a campaign fundraising group for
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi and
the reason for the donation is also part
of the scandal remember when Trump
University that scam I hate to even call
it university that is what it called
itself not really a university in any
reasonable sense when Trump University
was being investigated by a few state
attorneys general pam bondi was one of
them in florida looking into Trump
University and right after she decided
to stop the investigation in Florida
into Trump University in came a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar donation
from the trunk foundation to her
campaign to a probe on Deepak Trump also
held a fundraiser for her oh how nice
for him to do that and it was reported
that she is being considered for an
appointment in the Trump White House
let's take a look at a tweet from
Jennifer Jacobs who tweeted out she's a
White House reporter for bloomberg
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi will
be named to a post in the Trump White
House sources tell me Trump aids
finalizing her role it's unclear exactly
what the role would be this should be
front page bright red letters on Drudge
with the siren going around like crazy
crony capitalist is it did this is this
is filling the swamp whatever term you
want to use about that type of thing
crony capitalism draining the swamp
outside our establishment whatever you
want to talk about this is about as bad
as it gets Pat yeah this is an issue I
mean there were so many people during
the campaign who justified voting for
Donald Trump even though they found his
rhetoric to be offensive right even
though they disagreed with his politics
but they were able to put all of that
aside because they thought well at least
he's not business as usual it
not some normal politician he's gonna
drain the swamp and then he turns around
and does this yeah and remember I could
stand in the middle of Fifth Avenue
Rachel and shoot someone and I wouldn't
lose any voters he was probably right
about that appointing someone that he
made this clearly crony capitalist
contribution to right after the
investigation into Trump University was
dropped it should be front page page
headlines but the trumpets won't care
yeah I'm not sure if this is flooding
the swamp but I guess I'm just glad that
she's not going to be the director of
urban development writer Rubio sent her
a letter and said oh can you please
investigate the living situations in
bayside villas and she responded a month
later saying oh no this isn't a consumer
protection violation I'm out yeah Pam
Bondi would be maybe the only person
less qualified to be Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development than ben
Carson the guy who appears to be on his
way to being that uh again just about
everything Trump does and says and
implies is projection all that crooked
Hillary stuff it really seems like
crooked Trump is what we're talking
about Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home try-on to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses i
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / TDPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every
parent
sold Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at-home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker dot-com /
TDPS it costs nothing